Okay.
I've been thinking about whether or not to
do this story and it just has to be done.
All right.
Joe Biden is really weird about touching voters.
I'm not talking about the creepy uncle Joe
stuff related to women.
Okay?
I'm talking about something totally different
here.
I'm talking about how Joe Biden gets very
strange in even remotely contentious conversations
with men who ask him questions on the campaign
trail.
Now I'm going to show you two videos of this
normal caveat.
If Biden's the nominee, I'm voting for Biden.
This is not about anything other than this
is strange.
I'd be a hypocrite if I didn't point this
out since I point out strange behavior by
other candidates.
I talked about this in a recent livestream
and I pointed out Joe's behavior is oddly
aggressive towards voters and some people
immediately said, David, Joe's not aggressive.
You're just a beta male and you're uncomfortable
with confrontation.
First of all, this has nothing to do with
me and I encourage you to look at these videos.
If you're listening to the podcast or on the
radio, find the visual component we're going
to play and tell me this is normal behavior.
If you normally behave this way with people
around you in your real real life, I want
to follow you around and see who you're hanging
out with because how Joe Biden behaves in
these clips with voters is not normal.
Let's look at the first one from Iowa here
at Biden was asked about committing to phase
out fossil fuels and look at how Joe Biden
starts poking this guy in the chest and getting
aggressive with them.
This is not normal.
And as we look at the clip again this time
without audio, you see that the guy he's talking
to has this sort of uncomfortable smile on
his face because he recognizes Joe Biden's
behavior is abnormal.
Joe Biden, staffer or handler there.
That's a voice we've gotten to know well on
the campaign trail as she's often trying to
get people to move on and get Joe Biden away
from people.
She starts saying, move on, you know, get,
get a get a move on.
When Joe Biden starts getting irritated with
the voter.
Here's another example of this.
This one was when Biden was asked about some
of his views on fossil fuels.
This was at a Biden event and a guy showed
up, the guy had critical questions, tough
questions, but they are reasonable questions.
And again, Biden gets in, the guy's face,
gets really close to the guy, starts poking
the guy in the chest, eventually, um, uh,
tells the guy, find someone else to vote for,
go vote for someone else.
And you again hear that same handler say set.
Thank you so much trying to end it.
But Biden just insists on talking and pokes
the guy and then kind of holds on to the guy's
open coat.
Strange behavior.
Take a look.
Well then you want to replace his gas lines.
If that's not going to work, we got to stop
building and replacing pipe.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to put you in the general retreat
coming up and telling me you don't support
me.
I said, I will support you in general for
a primer.
That's good.
He's the guy that did more.
This is not about would I vote for Biden over
Trump?
Of course I would vote for Biden over Trump.
This is not about anything other than something
about the gleam and Joe Biden's eye when he
starts poking voters and treating them like
this is extremely odd and again to people
who saw me talk about this briefly on stream
and said, David, you're a beta.
This is not aggressive behavior.
This is how men interact when they have conversations.
Are you telling me this is how you are interacting
with people in your everyday life?
People you know, friends, family, coworkers.
I don't have anyone around me who, number
one treats people this way, or number two
would allow themselves to be treated this
way.
So if you watch these videos, and this strikes
you as the normal interactions of adults who
are talking, I want to hear from you because
maybe it's me in that you know, my sissy liberal
Northeastern city, as many of our viewers
like to say, but this is not normal behavior
that I've observed between adults anywhere.
This is the type of behavior I see between
drunk adults on the Las Vegas strip shortly
before they get into a fist fight.
Right?
That's what it reminds me of.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have a couple of these clips on our
Instagram page
at David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at
David dot.